mike reese espn nfl nation reporter
covering the patriots
and uh also an analyst for espn
boston.com kind enough to join us here
mike good morning thanks for joining us
how would you sum up the last couple of
days with the patriots
well uh you know for the players dan uh
totally topsy-turvy i think saturday
they get the word that
cam newton had tested positive for
covid19
and a lot of questions and a lot of
concerns you know i would say it
highlights to me the human side of the
game
you know initially some of the players
that i had communicated with said
we're really going to go forward and
play this game is it worth the risk of
doing so
and i think as we talk right now maybe
there's been a little more acceptance
among some of the players just to move
forward as time has passed a little bit
has cam spoken he hasn't he just posted
something on instagram
uh yesterday afternoon just saying you
know thank you for the love and support
and that he's going to take this time
to get healthy and that's really all
we've heard from cam
why brian hoyer not jared stood him
tonight
terrific question and really after all
off season
we've been talking how jared stood him
at the inside track right
to be tom brady's heir apparent and
let's say two things dan you know the
first thing when cam came in
july 8th that was like a last minute
type thing and
it was sort of clear like it was going
to be cam as long as it didn't go
sideways
but really everyone thought jarrett
would be the number two and
everything changed for him the fourth
day of training camp he
went to a boston hospital for tests on
his leg and the test came back
negative but when he was on the field
for the next practice
his reps were really diminished and it
sort of went from a three
picture quarterback snapshot to just two
and stidham never really developed any
momentum after that and
never really made a charge to sort of
change the team's mind that
he should be the number two guy so i
think the experience of hoyer here
is something they're a little more
comfortable with after that sort of
changed the fourth day of training camp
and also going on the road you'd
probably want to go with veteran
leadership with uh with hoyer but
how are how are the travel arrangements
different for the patriots for this game
as opposed to a normal game
well how about a 22-hour work day that's
basically what they're looking at check
this out
they woke up this morning before the sun
came up here in new england
they go to their facility to get tested
they board the buses and they head to
two different airports
one in boston one in providence you get
some of the players that have been in
close contact are all the players that
have been deemed to be in close contact
with cam
on one plane going to one airport and
then the other
rest of the team on another plane at a
different airport they're going to
arrive at around the same time
in kansas city later this morning
they'll have about three hours
at a hotel in kansas city then head to
arrowhead stadium for the game
hopefully put up for them you know a
competitive performance
and then hop back on the plane and get
back to gillette stadium let's say
three four in the morning eastern time
about 22 hour work day for them not
ideal but something that i
you know at the players i've
communicated with they've sort of
accepted this as the reality
was there any push by the patriots to
get this as a standalone game on tuesday
not that i have been able to discern in
in the people i've spoken with in fact
if anything they like the idea of
playing it tonight
because of the turnaround they have a
home game sunday
against the broncos and the idea of
playing tuesday
and then getting back in the middle of
the night and having that short
condensed time to get ready for their
next game at home i don't think was
my sense dan was that that wasn't viewed
as an ideal scenario for them
i know you've been covering this team
for a long time and they're there
every day but i've never heard bill
belichick talk about a player
the way he has spoken about cam newton
like the whole month
and i wondered if tom brady went a
couple of years without hearing
the niceties that cam got in one month
what's the logic because there's always
some kind of logic that's calculated
with bill belichick so
why the fawning over cam newton
oh i wish i had the answer like a lot of
things with this team
dan right you know i will say
in general and this is probably more
specific to
bill belichick i have personally noticed
a little bit of a softening
just overall this year not just with cam
but you know everything that's gone on
uh with covid19
he just lost his mother you know within
the last month
and i think just in general maybe the
whole virtual nature of our
interactions with him it's not as much
in his face
you know and i think he feels maybe more
comfortable
in these interactions and if i had to
say one thing like that's probably a
bunch of things but
that might be more of a factor than
anything related to the whole
bradycam comparisons and and you know
what damn maybe there's something to
the idea that he's done some research
with the people that have been around
cam in the past and maybe you know the
idea of building cam up is something
he's
learned from those that have coached cam
before is a good way to go
mike great stuff as always enjoy your
work on the mothership and thanks for
joining us we appreciate it
thanks for having me dan that's mike
reese espn nfl nation reporter covering
the patriots